Hi YouTube. Good morning from uh Toronto
on a very muggy day. As you know, last
night Trump ordered the bombing of three
Iranian
um nuclear facilities and this will mark
the beginning of World War II. So I have
both good news and bad news. Uh the bad
news is we are now approaching the end
of the world. The good news is this
morning I will tell you how the world
will end. So um I'm going to look ahead
and ask the most pivotal question of
this coming war which is will the United
States use ground troops? And as we
discussed many times before in previous
videos
if the United States were to use ground
troops then they would lose this war. it
would mark the end of the American
Empire and it would probably ignite the
Second American Civil War. Um, and I
think most people would be in agreement
that using ground troops would be a
disaster for the United States and the
United States should avoid uh using
ground forces uh to the best of its
ability.
That said, I'm going to use game theory
to explain to you why they will still
use ground troops against Iran even
though um it's a really really bad idea.
In fact, it it is a it would be a
catastrophe. Okay, so let's do some game
theory analysis. In game theory, we look
at the in we look at the different
players here be Iran, Israel, the United
States and we ask three questions. The
first question is how do they themselves
perceive the game? What game are they
playing? How do they see themselves? Um
how do they see their roles in this
game? That's the first big question.
Second big question is what are their
interests? What are their motivations?
What are they trying to accomplish? What
are their goals? The third big question
then is given their role and given um
their interest, what is their optimal
strategy in trying to achieve their
goals. Okay. So given these three
questions, we're going to look at um how
Iran, Israel, United States will play
this game um in this war. Okay. So
Iran's probably easiest to do so Iran.
Iran perceives this war um as the
opportunity to achieve really important
national strategic goals. The first is
to create national unity and to further
legitimize the authority of the regime.
Um as you know because of of sanctions
and because of mismanagement because of
corruption this regime in Iran is not
very popular. But if the Americans are
coming to invade and overthrow the
regime and sow chaos and destruction,
then the people are going to solidly
unite behind the government, no matter
what government it is. Um, also, uh, the
Iranians see this as the best
opportunity in a long time to finally
destroy the American presence in the
Middle East by forcing the Americans
into a quagmire that that they cannot
extricate themselves from. As we
discussed many times, supply issues in
Iran will be a huge problem for the
American military. they they can get in,
but it's be very hard for them to get
out. Um, and the third strategic
national interest is to um create global
legit legitimacy by defeating the
Americans, right? uh the Shia regime is
trying to be the leaders of the global
Muslim movement and if they were to
defeat the Americans in Iran then they
would be become the de facto leaders of
all Muslims in the world surpassing
Saudi Arabia. So those are the three
major national strategic interests of
Iran. And now the question then is how
would Iran force Americans to invade?
What is the optimal strategy in this
regard? Because remember the the
Iranians um they're not going to be able
to beat the Americans in a conventional
war. They don't have the technology.
They don't have the weapons. They don't
have the financing that the Americans
do. So, they're going to have to trap
the Americans in um uh Iran, encircle
them, and cut off their supply lines and
force a negotiated surrender. Okay,
that's that's the optimal strategy of
the Iranians. So why would the Americans
be lured into attacking Iran on Iran's
terms? Well, um there's a concept in
geopolitics, in political science,
called the escalation ladder. Um the
idea of the escalation ladder is that
before uh a full-blown war can start,
there has to be a certain process of
escalation.
And in this theory, the Americans have
something called escalation dominance,
which means that um the Americans can
always choose use nuclear weapons uh if
they choose if they feel they are losing
this war. They are the hegeimon. They
are the global hegeimon and the Iranians
are the underdog. So in theory, what
they teach you in polic science is that
the hegeimon has advantage of escalation
dominance. What I want to show you today
is actually um this theory doesn't
really work because exclusion dominance
what it does is it forces you into
reactions that may be that may be
against your best interest. So let me
use a metaphor. Let's just say there's a
bully in a high school and he's been
bullying people for a year now and he's
the biggest guy in the school. He's
really mean and everyone's afraid of
him. He has a reputation for being a
thug and that's why he's able to
accomplish what he wants to accomplish.
Now, let's just say that you you're, you
know, half his size. You want to start a
fight with him. Well, um you would think
that that would be against your
advantage. But one advantage that you
have um in this fight is you can control
the terms of engagement. you can uh
calibrate your actions to in order to
elicit responses that are to the
detriment of the bully. Okay. So, what I
mean by that is if
um the bully punches you, well, you have
options. You can choose to go to the
principal, you can choose to not do
anything or you can choose to fight
back. Okay? You have some options. But
if you were to punch the bully, the
bully would have actually no choice but
to punch you back. If he relents, if he
compromises, then he loses all
credibility in the school. So, he has
absolutely no choice in the matter but
to punch you back and punch you back
harder than you uh punched him. Um, and
what this means is there are ways for
you to calibrate your attack so that the
bully is trapped. Okay? So, for example,
you might say some bad things about him
behind um uh his back, then he responds.
And anyway, the point of the matter is
even though the bully has the is
supposed to be the uh stronger player,
um he's forced by his reputation to
respond in a certain way that you can
control and calibrate. Same situation
here um with Iran versus United States.
The United States is a global hedgeimon.
If if Iran were to close off the street
of Humus, if it were to attack Saudi
Arabia, if it were to attack American
bases in uh the Middle East, then the
Americans must respond in a way that
that demonstrates escalation dominance.
Okay? And so by slowly and methodically
and steadily provoking the Americans in
a way that um seems fair and reasonable,
then Iran can slowly force the Americans
into evading uh Iran. Okay? It's a it's
going be a gradual process, but the
Iranians can do this. Remember, it's the
Americans who first launched the first
strike against the Iranians. And so the
Iranians can now calibrate response in
order to slowly trap the Americans in
the Middle East. Okay. So um from
Iranian perspective, the optimal
strategy is to force Americans to uh use
ground troops to invade Iran. Uh, and
they can accomplish that by carefully
calibrating responses in a way that
forces the Americans to respond more
harshly until finally the only the only
option really is to use ground troops.
Okay, that's the Iranian case study.
Now, let's look at the Israelis. Okay,
the Israelis and the Americans seem to
be allies in this war. But the reality
is the Americans and the Israelis have
divergent interests. America is the
global hegeimon. Therefore, it wants to
be able to balance uh forces in the
Middle East. Um yes, it supports Israel
right now, but if Israel were to become
too powerful over time, then the
Americans would start to back Saudi
Arabia, Turkey,
um Egypt. Okay? The Americans must
maintain bounds of power in the Middle
East. The Israelis on the other hand
want to be the dominant hegeimon in the
Middle East. There's something called
the greater Israel project um that uh
among certain circles in Israel is an
extremely influential
um idea. Okay. And the idea is very
simple. They believe that in the Bible,
Yahweh, their God, um gave the promised
land to uh Abraham. That's a covenant.
The promised land though is is extends
from the Nile to the Euphrates. That
entire basically the entire Middle East
is supposed is supposed to be what um
Yahweh promised Abraham. And there's a
fanatical faction within the Israeli
government that seeks to accomplish the
uh promised land. And of course um if
that were the case then the main
adversaries to this project would not be
the Iranians or the Saudis. It would
actually be the Americans. Okay? Because
um to accomplish the uh Israel the
greater Israel project then then Israel
needs to remove America from the Middle
East. So, how can Israel do this? Well,
let's just say um just hypothetically
speaking, um the Americans were to
invade Iran with ground troops and
they're stuck there for years and years
and they get nowhere. Um now the
American Empire collapses. The American
people revolt against the uh invasion of
Iran. They refuse to serve. Um they burn
uh their draft cards as they did in
Vietnam. There's civil chaos. There's
there's there's an emerging civil war in
uh America. And now the the American
military is forced to retreat from the
Middle East. What would happen in that
situation? Well, the moment that the
American Empire dies,
the empire of Israel is born. Why?
Because controlling the Middle East, the
American military controlling the Middle
East is called Sencom, Central Command.
They have bases, they have weapons, they
have soldiers. If the American nation
were to retreat from the Middle East, it
does not mean the American military goes
away. All it means is the American
military will now become absorbed
into the nation state of Israel, making
Israel the de facto um hegeimon of the
Middle East. Okay, that's the long-term
play of Israel. It does Israel
absolutely no good to defeat Iran. They
need to both defeat Iran and America.
The best way to do that is to entangle
both into war that will destroy the
militaries of of both nations. Okay,
that's the optimal strategy for Israel.
And that requires the Israelis to
persuade the Americans to use ground
troops to invade Iraq. Okay, that's the
Israel
um case study. Now, let's look at
America. Obviously, America does not
want to use ground troops uh because the
moment that Americans start dying in the
Middle East, uh the moment that they
institute a draft, it will create chaos
in America. People are going to protest,
people are going to revolt. Um,
politically speaking, it will be a
quagmire. What the American Empire wants
to do is um use
bombing, propaganda, and financing. And
this something we discussed um last
video to overthrow the Iranian regime,
the Aatollah and his mas, and install a
more friendly regime that they can
control. And in that way they can
control all the resources, the oil of
the Middle East and they can control
global trade as well. And they have to
do this as a response to Putin's
invasion of Ukraine which really put the
American Empire on the uh back foot.
Okay. So that's the optimal strategy of
the American Empire. Okay. to overthrow
the regime with as little casualties
um as possible uh hopefully through
bombing, decapitation strikes, killing
the Alatola um special forces strategies
basically. Okay. But the person leading
the American empire right now is Donald
Trump. And if we look at what he wants,
it's actually not it's actually
different from the what the American
Empire wants. Let's ask ourselves a
question. What game is Donald Trump
playing? Does he really care about Iran?
Does he really care about the Middle
East? Does he really care about Israel
and Zionism and the Greater Israel
Project? My guess is he does not care.
What he cares about is maintaining his
political authority and power within the
United States. He also cares about
destroying the global elite that in his
mind robbed him of power in 2022.
Remember for Trump the 2020 2020 sorry
the 2020 elections were stolen from him.
It's something that that um he's been
adamant about for the past four years.
In fact, he stews over it. So he wants
to get back at the global elite who
stole uh the American election from him
and also wants to make sure he stays in
power. That means destroying the global
elite and the American empire. Okay, so
it's really a struggle between America
first represented by Donald Trump and
American Empire. Now, you would think
that this war uh between the American
first people and the American Empire
would mean that Donald Trump would not
use ground troops into in Iran. But what
better way to destroy the American
Empire than to give it what what all
that it wants? Okay. What better way
destroy the American empire by making it
arrogant
um and by giving it all it wants and by
um putting in a situation that it cannot
possibly win. Right? So the idea is
this. The idea is at first Donald Trump
will seem to want regime change in Iran.
Um, and he may even commit ground
troops, but as um the American people
start protesting, as there's violence
and civil strike within America, as
American soldiers are start to die in
Iran, as the glo economy collapses, then
Donald Trump's going to want to change
his mind, right?
But the American Empire is fully
committed to winning this war. It wants
it's allin. Um it refuses to surrender.
And now a conflict emerges between the
American Empire and America first. And
Donald Trump can now um aggravate this
tension by standing with America first
over the American empire. And this would
lead to a civil war. And you think you
would think this is a bad thing, but the
civil war and an unwinable war in the
Middle East uh are going to greatly
enhance the power and authority of
Donald Trump. So much so that he would
probably able be able to capture a third
term. Okay. So, um it's really
interesting in that, um
all three major players, Donald Trump,
Israel, and Iran want America to use
ground troops in Iran for their own
selfish uh individual individualistic
uh purposes. And that's why I think
ground troops will eventually be used in
Iran.
Um, and I think what will happen is that
basically all three players, Iran,
Israel, um, and and Donald Trump will
get exactly what they want. Um, Israel
will be able to remove America from the
Middle East and become the empire of
Israel.
Iran will unite the Muslim world behind
its leadership. And Donald Trump will
probably get his third term. Okay,
that's what I see um the um um upshot of
this war being. Now, this raises a lot
of questions though, right? I mean, if
Israel becomes greater Israel and it
becomes the empire of Israel and
dominates the Middle East, controlling
oil and trade, then wouldn't the world
unite against Israel? And unfortunately,
that's part of the plan. That's part of
the prophecy. Okay. And this is
something that we will discuss in the in
the uh next video because using game
theory itself is not you you it's not
enough to fully explain understand
what's going on in the Middle East. To
fully understand what's going on in my
next in my next video, I'm going to
explain to you the religious
um ideals, the religious um obsessions
driving this war in the Middle East. I'm
going explain to you the idea of
esquetology which means the
understanding
um of how the world ends. Basically all
the major players in the game Iran,
Israel, even to a certain extent the
United States, the Christian Zionist in
the United States see this war in Iran
as the fulfillment of biblical prophecy.
It really they really see this as the
end of the world. And that's why this
war is so scary for all of us. And um so
in my next video I will reveal to you
the religious dimensions of this war.
Okay.
Um some other points before I conclude
this video.
Some of you have reached out um in my
last video and said that I should not u
reveal my public um information. I
shouldn't put my family in front of the
camera. And you're absolutely right. Um,
upon reflection, I want to thank
everyone who voiced their concerns. Um,
honestly, this is all new to me. I was a
high school teacher teaching my students
and now I'm internet famous and
everyone's looking to me for some
guidance um, as to this US Iran war. And
I'm flattered um, but I'm also
overwhelmed by the attention. I'm an ed
I'm an educator. I want to continue to
educate people on how this war is going
to unfold so that you will be better
prepared. Um I I see that as my my
mission. And so I'm going to continue
making videos. I'm going to continue as
this war progresses um explaining to you
using game theory how this war how the
hell how this war might unfold. Um but
um I now understand that the internet
can be a scary, crazy,
insane place. So, I'm have to be much
more careful about my public profile and
I'm I have to be a lot more careful
about protecting my family. Okay. So,
I'm going to keep on making videos. Um,
but I apologize if you reach out and I
don't really answer you. Uh, I'm being
I'm I'm being overwhelmed right now. I
apologize if you reach out and you want
to have coffee and I can't do it. Um,
again, my focus right now is on studying
this war, trying to figure out what's
going on, and in my and to the best of
my ability, try to explain and clarify
what's going on. Okay, so I will see
everyone next time. Goodbye.